so wait one of the things that you're
promoting is your seventh album so what
sets this one apart because i feel like
every album i've come out with it's very
different i'm in a very different place
so what is this one nice candid photo i
had no idea i love it
i love it
it's it's you like classic songs i do i
do i love i love orchestras i love the
sound of great arrangements
um
uh great orchestrator andrew cotty um
terrific producer joel mcnealy who
writes a lot of music for me both worked
on this album um it's it's an uptempo uh
uh swing album that's um that uh should
should make people feel pretty happy
yeah that's what i love about this show
you get to do different songs but i
think that's what i i love i think you
like robbie williams has done it a bit
like it's like i like that people do
that throwback sound it's i mean amy
winehouse made a whole career off of
like doing a throwback vibe to that so
it's really cool i don't think enough
people appreciate those orchestral
arrangements and how beautiful it is
yeah well you mean you listen you listen
to the sinatra ballot albums like only
the lonely and we small hours and and
you know as great a vocalist as he was
you take the vocals out of it you listen
to what's going on yeah with the
orchestra there's really nothing like
that today it's beautiful one of my
favorite songs of all time is something
stupid like i love you he did with him
sure sure yeah so if you ever covered
that song and you're like who will sing
this with me i will okay all right all
right cause i love that song
and i listen i listen to snatch all the
time i love it it's just such a peaceful
vibe and it's so pretty and it i get i
think old music like that too like older
music gives space it gives space to
breathe and now we're trying to fill all
the moments it does and it's and it's
and it's roboto which means there's not
always a tempo i know the orchestra and
the singer in the same room yeah i have
my own tempo this is a joke in my band
for like 20 years they're like this is
kelly time it's like because i'm
it's like singer time like i just want
to hold this out as long as i want to
and then come back when i want to
[Music]
you